[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
this is the ramsey show we help people
build wealth
do work that they really love
and create actual amazing relationships
rachel cruz number one best-selling
author ramsey personality and my
daughter is my co-host today as we
answer your questions about building
wealth doing work you love and amazing
actual
relationships so rachel i'll do
something i don't usually do i'm going
straight to the mailbag we don't usually
pull up emails on the show 2007.
i read this occasionally i'll pull off
something that we get into customer care
hate mail or
uh trolls or actual just funny stuff or
really inspiring things that customers
do and you used to read it and i read it
to the uh to the staff meeting or
twitter i haven't done that in a while i
feel like i read i read this one monday
morning
whatever it was the other day and so
james our producer says you got to read
this the audience okay so dave thanks
for your practical and entertaining
advice you and the team put on the
ramsey show we're debt free including
our house worth over two million dollars
we presented our final mortgage check to
chase bank in hollywood california
the journey to the bank included driving
past a man dressed as marilyn monroe
riding a bicycle
a 70 year old woman wearing tight animal
print driving a hot pink corvette
once at the bank the person ahead of us
in line was covered in tattoos on her
face
when we handed the teller the check they
congratulated us and then my husband
turned to me and said we're the weirdest
people in hollywood
[Laughter]
which is a high bar is the point huge
thanks to you and the entire ramsey team
for your guidance and inspiration we
couldn't have done it without you way to
go guys that's a lot of fun that's funny
we're the weirdest people in hollywood
you're so weird we say that all the time
but really not exactly in that context
but that's that's just straight up funny
that's great open phones here at
825-5225
matt's in albuquerque new mexico hey
matt how are you
i'm doing fine uh thank you very much
dave and rachel for taking my call i
appreciate it sure what's up
i
i feel really kind of bad asking this
because so many people having a rough go
of it and suffering everything and yet
my question seems so you know their
success does not cause their problems
okay well i appreciate that
anyway uh what i would like to know is
if i can get a uh objective answer to
the question of whether
i can afford or should uh purchase or
get into a golf club golf club
membership absolutely you should no i'm
kidding i was like
any of these are good with me i'm good
with all of them so uh uh
all kidding aside uh
you know
obviously it's not a moral question it's
just a ratios thing
if it is a small enough percentage of
your life that it doesn't matter
mathematically then obviously you should
do it
if you're going to spend your kids
college tuition to join a golf club no
be a man don't do that
no it's it's not that the golf club
membership
um
in the initiation fee plus you know
getting the cart itself would run uh
thirty thousand dollars and then the uh
uh
the monthly
uh dues after that
is
roughly 550 600 a month it's pretty
reasonable for most golf clubs
hopefully it's a decent track right
yeah it's it's a real nice and it's a
real nice uh course yeah what do you
make of your community with it what do
you make a year
household income
is around 165 okay and what's your net
worth
uh
including property and all of that good
stuff in the neighborhood of uh 1.5
million okay and you're debt free
debt free no mortgage no credit card no
nothing except monthly bills
matt i think you've just joined the
country club
yeah i think you're fine yeah i think
you're fine
your only problem is you're still a
tight wad that's your only problem
see that yeah it kind of you know uh it
kind of hurt a little bit you know
because that's a lot of money for
initial outlay and there was a time you
know six months ago i cancelled an mp3
purchase because they had risen the
price from 99 cents to 1.29 so you know
i just that's just yeah that's horrible
i can't believe that they would do that
to a man like you but um and matt i'm
assuming too you're going to use the
membership correct like you enjoy
golfing you're going to be using it it's
not like oh i'm just going to do it it's
going to just sit there and it's a waste
you're going to be using it yeah i'm not
going to yeah i'm not going to just say
hey look what i got no absolutely i'm
going to be hacking away so
matt that's the y'all are like throwing
out golf terms that i have no idea what
you mean so i'm assuming that's a golf
yeah it just means he's going to dig
holes in the golf course
yeah what i would encourage matt is that
you know we talk about
here on the show so often that you live
like no one else and that's what you
hear a lot on the show is the sacrifice
that people are taking
currently to get out of debt to build up
an emergency fund to get to a point
where their heads above water
but then to later to live and give like
no one else and so you're just at the
that other end of the equation and a lot
of people struggle
in that latter part of the equation
because they're like oh gosh like
yeah if spending money feels weird or i
feel wasteful is this okay they ask all
the same questions you ask and so um so
what i'm always looking for
it to make it a wise decision and also
to make it emotionally palatable is
ratios
okay
how big a percentage of your world is
this and thirty thousand dollars is a
percentage of 1.5 or as a percentage of
165 000 income with somebody completely
debt free it's like buying a biscuit
dude
i mean it's not it's not going to affect
your life
if you take thirty thousand dollars and
put it in the middle of the floor and
burn it
your life is not gonna change
no okay that's my point and so that
means you can afford this and it because
you don't even notice it doesn't affect
your giving it doesn't affect your
investing it affects your enjoyment of
life and it's there's three things you
can do with money you can enjoy it you
can give it and you can invest it and
you should always be doing all three but
look at the ratios
and the ratios set you free because i
used to be that guy i was that guy said
no one needs to drive a car that
expansive
because i'm like managing other people's
lives or something and that's just a
bunch of crap that's just poor mouthing
is what we call it i mean that's just
you grow up in a neighborhood where you
run down rich people you know and it's
like you wouldn't see every guy because
who needs to carry your expenses well i
can tell you who doesn't need it
somebody can't pay for it and that they
notice when they buy it but i got a
friend that made 15 million dollars last
year and he drove it in front of my
house in a 300 000 lamborghini
so but you know what that's a smaller
percentage he spent on his car of his
income than you spent on your car all of
you listening
so shut up
it's nunya
nunya business what he drives and it's
not affecting him it's a z it's a i mean
300 000 is a percentage of 15 million so
if you make 150 000 that'd be like
minute uh a 3 000 car
okay
same exact ratios
so it's
so you know he about shut up
you got a full-time job managing your
life
jeez
this great job matt touchdown i'm proud
of you go get the dadgum golf membership
you're awesome this is the ramsey chef
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
right now to get their free white paper
jump start your cfo career
[Music]
so
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today case in ontario hi kate
welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave hey rachel thank you so much
for taking my call dave i have to talk
to you in george back in december my
grandmother passed away and is leaving
me about 150 000
canadian dollars
the probate period's ending i'm probably
going to receive the money at the end of
the month and i'm having a disagreement
with my parents about what i would like
to do with money versus what they would
like me to do with the money i'd really
like to honor both my
grandparents and my parents how old are
you and i just hope your advice
how old are you
oh i'm 30. why do your parents get a
vote in this
well they gave me 60 000 my husband 50
000 very generously when we bought our
starter home did they give it to you or
did they loan it to you and say they get
to tell you how to run your life after
that
no sir they gave it to us as a very
generous that's sweet that's sweet until
they until they use that as the guilt
trip ticket
so you should
continue to fully fund our emergency
fund which is about halfway there and
then put the rest towards our mortgage
we should pay about 80 percent of it
down there's two different things going
on here okay you're asking me what to do
with it
and you're discussing your parents
wanting to tell you what to do with it
those are two different subjects okay
okay all right rachel so what i'm
curious what do your parents want you to
do because i just heard what you want to
do what do they want you to do my
parents want me to put it in retirement
accounts basically the canadian
equivalent of roth and ira as well as do
some home repairs
so what's what is it for you kate though
that that kind of back to dave's
question of that need to
really feel the weight of what they're
saying are they making you feel so
guilty like what why
why don't you just go and do what you
want to do
they're not making me feel guilty
they're really wonderful people who have
done a lot on their own and they have
really won with money and been great
examples to me that i feel i should but
what you're suggesting you want to do
with money is not dumb
well i didn't think so well no it's not
i mean it's exactly what we teach so
obviously we think it's not dumb but
also i mean you didn't suggest you you
go
uh
you know somehow you blow the money or
you're irresponsible with money
okay
let me let me run a parallel for you
okay
this is how my mind works and i can't
help it um but
you know rachel's little brother daniel
is 31 right
i don't know how old my brother is but
it sounds about right
and so if if he and his wife allison
got a hundred and fifty thousand dollars
i am very loud
i am very opinionated
and when it comes to this particular
subject i'm very right
okay
but i still the chances of me
and rachel back me up on this
the chances of me
calling daniel and allison up out of the
blue and saying here's what you should
do with money that you got from
allison's parents or got from whatever
other source is zero now if they ask
i'll tell them what i think they should
do
but i'm not going to withhold love
if they don't do it
i'm not going to roll my eyes if they
don't do it um they're like grown people
and stuff
you see is that i mean that's how we
would function right now 100 yes for
sure but but kate i have for you
do you feel like you're going to get
that the role of the eye the oh my gosh
i can't believe you did that kate that
that feeling from your parents or do you
think they're gonna say
oh
we just think that this was a better
idea but you go do like
is there that sticking point
i think they might be disappointed that
i maybe didn't take their advice and i
took dave ramsey's advice instead but i
don't think they would
i don't think it would be a
thanksgiving okay dinner i mean here
here's so for you though you're just
struggling between are they right or is
this right sorry go what exactly exactly
and i want to if i go ahead and make
like the dave ramsey stream decision i
want to do it in a way and explain it to
them in a way that you know says that's
what i would like to do and i'd like to
honor you and honor my grandparents in
this
absolutely
absolutely so go
he's like dying over here
um
i appreciate you wanting them to be
happy with your decision
but your need for their approval just
needs to stop
okay the boundaries are just they're
they're walking all in your yard with
muddy boots they need to get back in
their yard
they came across they came in they came
across the fence they just came across
the fence and you know you don't have to
be mean about it and i'm not suggesting
you be caustic and this isn't really
about their advisor dave ramsey's advice
this is about like you being a grown up
and stuff
and you get to make your decisions and
you decided you were going to you
gathered up information from several
different sources and then you made the
decision what you wanted to do with your
money
it's not like oh i picked dave ramsey
over i picked my parents no you know
you're not doing that that's not what's
going on here what's really going on
here is you gathered information from
several different places you think that
this particular method is the best okay
rachel gathered several pieces of
information from different places and
bought a freaking tesla
how in the world but she did and we're
making you know we make fun of her all
the time but um and we joke about it but
the point is
even as you know we joke about it and
the chances of me she she did not follow
her parental guidance when she purchased
a car that it runs on a battery that her
father would never do that not going
against and so but i you know all we
have done
is
celebrate that she loves the car and
joke about it that's all we've done
there's been no me walking over in your
boundary scene you shouldn't do that
that's a dumb idea stop being stupid i
never i never did any of that no no
but kate i would say when you explain it
to your parents because you're like yeah
they're probably gonna be disappointed
so yes the boundaries is a whole issue i
shouldn't be disappointed
i'm not disappointed that you bought a
tesla i make fun of it but i'm not
disappointed no no but kate i think too
to explain it to them though like like
um
that your quickest way to honor
them honor your grandparents all the
language you're using
and to help you and your family win you
and you your husband win
with money the fastest way to get from
point a to point b of what you see is to
have what's wise as an emergency fund in
the bank you're having an emergency fund
in the bank uh paying off any debt that
you have being able to take some of that
and pay off your mortgage so that way
you guys don't have a mortgage payment
so that so that you can
invest and all that because their advice
is not necessarily it's not the order we
would do it but investing that money
it's not like they're giving you bad
advice you could invest that money and
be totally
great kate but but the steps before that
and explaining to them like hey here's
what here's how i'm seeing it
to be wise to get to that point and then
i will then i will be able to invest and
have the margin to invest a lot i think
john delaney would disagree with you
really to explain it to him no i think
he would just say listen i appreciate
your input you don't get a vote okay but
if kate's not i'm thinking if i'm in her
shoes though and i feel
like a oh gosh you know and again this
isn't you guys but i'm like if if i had
parents saying that to me
she she's at the point though that she's
taking their
their opinion with such weight for her
to just eliminate that that doesn't
happen overnight so for her to make this
decision though in the next week you
just smile at him and say honey you
don't get a vote
you can be nicer about than that honey
hey you're you didn't tell your mother
and i well the name of your children
before they were born because you were
afraid your mother would roll her eyes
okay
because we don't get a vote it's your
freaking kid you get to name the kid we
hope you don't name them moonbeam
but but you get to name the kids my mom
goes oh god please don't name them
anything weird i was like exactly i'm
not telling you the baby names so
exactly you and all you said was in a
nice way you don't get a vote my kid in
my body i name it
you know and that's that's healthy
boundaries no but what do you say to
kate who doesn't she needs to put up
healthy boundaries she does but i think
having a conversation explaining why
she's making this decision is not wrong
it's not i don't they don't get a vote
they don't get a vote so they don't need
to be persuaded oh my gosh no she's
making her decision to do the emergency
fund and pay off the mortgage but i
think it's totally fine relationally to
go into her parents and say hey here's
why i i've chosen to do it you don't get
a vote but here's why and explain the
why that's not wrong
if you want to it's okay but dial up
daloni you didn't explain me why you
named your kid that and you didn't
explain to me why you bought a tesla and
i still don't want to get gas anymore i
know but i didn't you didn't offer you
didn't owe me an explanation no i
no i don't but if i was worried about it
i probably would give you an explanation
but i'm not worried about it because you
don't care see there it is it's healthy
boundaries that's it you got it
it is wonderful i love it
kate bottom line is do what you wanna do
with your money i would recommend but we
always recommend we hope you do that and
we love you anyway
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and churchill is here to help
go to their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage ken and laura are with
us hey guys how are you good how are you
great better than we deserve where do
you all live knoxville knoxville what
part of knoxville we actually live in
powell just north knoxville yeah
well rachel's husband's from knoxville i
was born in marvel so we're from all
from over that direction so welcome to
nashville good to have you how much debt
have you paid 23 000 good very good for
you and how long did that take a year
one year and your range of income during
that time started out at 76 000 and then
was up to 81 000. cool what kind of debt
was the 23 my car your car
our car
that's simple the one that you drive
that's our car yes
all right so uh how long you all been
married
15 years next month okay so what was the
thing that happened a year ago that just
you said okay so it started really about
five years ago my work had a lunch and
learn about being financially fit and i
never considered financial fitness just
always physical so i went to it and i
was kind of intrigued and that kind of
started to snowball from there
so
over the next course of a couple of
years we kind of talked about like we
weren't going to be able to retire i
hadn't put anything in retirement in
probably 10 to 12 years he was only
putting in five percent and just like
that we needed to get our act together
so i had been praying i was just nervous
and scared and code came along and then
um
i providentially found your radio show
started listening and it took me a while
to get on board because we used our
credit cards and got our cash back and
all that kind of stuff
and so then um rachel's book know
yourself now your money was coming out
and the wallet and so i had never used a
debit card i don't think i had one and
so that was my first debit card purchase
and then from that moment i was like we
can't i can't put credit cards in that
wallet
i'm so proud of you i'm so glad that
like with the motivation this little
thing down inside of it it just just it
distinguishes whether it's debit or
credit and it destroys it as soon as you
put it in
i love it that's awesome yeah
that's amazing okay so so now then you
come back to ken and you know okay uh
i'm about to get us weird and what'd ken
say
um well
she was all gung-ho and i was like oh
this was this is a little
this is kind of weird
and just kind of he was like we we we
you have to have credit cards everybody
has credit cards
we can't live without them
a little while before we got turned down
at a car company because we didn't have
a credit card with us
right around this time so we had to go
home
get a credit card to put the deposit
down to get the car so i'm like you kind
of need a credit card for emergencies
but
no
and now you're you're surviving without
them yeah look at them
i don't know ken's too excited about it
that's so funny okay so what so but the
only debt you guys had was this car was
the car that he used a credit card to do
the down payment on yeah well and we had
always
um
we had kind of got into that got out
like we bought his truck paid it off
early went into student loan debt paid
it off within like a year or two and we
just kept doing that and i knew really
like inside like that's not how i want
to live that's not where i want to be
but we would keep going back to it so i
feel like you work for the bank yeah
yeah and i had been listening when i
would pick my girls up every day from
school i would listen from two to four
we would hear the debt free screams and
so i heard one that was almost exactly
the same amount that we owed same amount
of money and i was just thinking there's
no excuse that we can't do this
that's amazing amazing and then you guys
did it i mean you said okay we're gonna
do this so
i'm curious ken
what would you say to the wife listening
right now
who wants her husband on board
but he won't get on board what was it
that helped you
decide okay we can do this and i'm gonna
i'm gonna jump in and we're gonna do
this weird plan of paying off the car
uh well it's really
laura has really good intuition
intuition and it's
this is more her area than mine um i'm
the nerd
yeah
so i i guess it's really just you know
do you really trust your your wife i
mean
i do
i mean up until my job now i never even
knew what my paycheck was i mean i never
even looked at it yeah and so
you know i just fully trust her in
everything and she thought this was a
really good idea and
so
even though it was kind of against my
raisin i you know
am on board everybody's raised yeah it's
against everybody because everybody's
raised to stay in debt yeah get in debt
stay in debt your whole life that's how
we were all taught
yeah that's cool good so how does it
feel now it feels good great i feel like
it was just so empowering like we can do
anything if something happened and our
income decreased or one of us lost a job
like we're going to be able to manage it
yeah we'll be okay
anybody cheering you on from the
sidelines
they're girls yeah mainly our daughters
yeah they were really big
we would go to the store one of them
would have the grocery list and the
other one would have a calculator and
they'd be like mom we're getting close
to the amount like oh we can't put that
in that's not on the list that's good
yeah that's a great great exercise for
those young ladies
to learn to learn to say no to budget
within or to live within an amount and
make this make decisions because you got
to okay if i want to put that in the
buggy i can't put these two things in
the bucket you got to decide and you
have to do that your whole life really
all of us do so not just the grocery
store but everywhere and that's that's
the thing so way to go you guys where
you going very proud of you how's it
feel to be free
wonderful feels good i wish we had found
it and started sooner will you go back
in debt no no no done done all right
good for y'all very cool well let's
bring the girls up to give us their
names and ages please
we've got
lexie and abby and they're both 10
they're twins oh wonderful so fun okay
rachel's mom's a twin so there you go
good stuff fun stuff well we've got a
copy of baby steps millionaires for you
how ordinary people built extraordinary
wealth how you can too that's the next
chapter in your story you guys going to
be millionaires now you're on your way
you make a 80 000 bucks a year you don't
have any payments you can do it it's
very very very possible one-third of the
millionaires that we studied never made
six figures
so it's very possible good stuff also
got a copy of the book the total money
makeover that almost 10 million folks
have followed to do the stuff that
you're doing the baby steps the whole
thing you can give that away to somebody
help them get started and we've got a
copy of the financial peace university
uh one year subscription to fpu and
every dollar through the ramsey plus
subscription and we'll give you that as
well you can go through the class if you
want if you have already been through it
give it to somebody else we want you to
pay it all forward and give you some
stuff to help some other folks so way to
go you guys we're very proud of y'all
you're awesome you're heroes thank you
well done well done good excuse to come
over to nashville and hang out yes
i like it good stuff all right it's ken
and laura and abby and lexi from
knoxville 23 000 paid off in one year
making 76-81
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three two one we're done
fabulous
very well done you guys very well done
nick is in omaha nebraska hi nick how
can we help
well i got a couple questions about
student loans
um thanks for taking my call first sure
um so i attended a corinthian college
and
there was a thing signed earlier this
month about cancelling debt yep your
debt will be forgiven if you have a
federal student loan
so i have two federal student loans
technically with both from corinthian
yes one's a parent plus one which i
promised to pay and one's underneath
mine they're both gone
they're both gone so then so technically
i'm on baby step three right now uh well
you got to go through the process i mean
you're going to get with the government
and work through it but uh the standard
okay biden came out said i forgave five
billion dollars worth of student loan
debt bull crap he did not the standard
procedure with the department of
education is if a private college like
corinthian college goes broke the
federal government has always canceled
all of the student loans associated with
that college they've always done that
that's a standard thing biden didn't do
that
it was going to happen whether biden was
in office or trump was in office or
whoever was in office it's just it's the
way the program works and so he wants to
take political credit for it but he
didn't do squat
so
the but the debt is forgiven the stupid
college went broke they ripped you off
and you get your debt completely
forgiven now you have to go through that
process so yeah mathematically you're
not paying any more on these debts and
you're gonna walk out of this uh
completely but you're gonna go through
the paperwork and you're gonna have to
deal with the department of education
and fill out the forms and do all the
stuff so that it goes away because it
doesn't just poof disappear how does it
do it do you know it's a process i mean
it's like a series of papers yeah the
paper you fill out series of forms you
fill out just like if you become
disabled your federal student loans are
forgiven but you have to go prove the
disability you have to fill out the
paperwork they don't just automatically
call you up and go hey i heard you're
disabled we're forgiven no you got to go
you got to go make the thing happen yep
yep this is the ramsay shot
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today
there's so much crazy going on and
people are looking for direction on how
to handle their finances day to day but
they're also struggling to see if it's
even possible to build wealth out there
right now
at our building wealth live event
we're going to talk to you
through all the crazy
through all recession talk
high gas prices
high interest rates how are you going to
become wealthy
it's not by going stupid i can tell you
that
and getting in some kind of
get-rich-quick garbage we're going to
show you how to really build wealth in
good times and in bad times and we do
that at these building wealth live
events we just finished up a couple of
them they were sold out in vegas sold
out in orlando
the phoenix event is september the 13th
sacramento november the 1st minneapolis
is november the 10th and san antonio is
november the 15th they are all 80 sold
so if you want to come you're not going
to be able to wait until the fall to buy
your tickets right before the event
they're going to be gone
so we want you to get your tickets now
so that you can uh actually pull this
off it's gonna be great rachel cruz will
be with me george campbell ken coleman
dr john deloney we can't wait to see you
guys we love going out into the public
seeing human beings we think this is
important humans need to see humans it's
a good thing
and uh
event passes start as low as 25 dollars
you can get a four pack as low as sixty
dollars so bring your friends it's going
to be amazing get four up before your
buddies up let's go go to
ramseysolutions.com events get your
seats now our question of the day comes
from blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings with free samples free
shipping and the new promos they run
every month you'll save even more use
the promo code ramsay to get the best
deal today's question comes from kate
and oregon my husband and i are on baby
step two and are getting close to
obvious step three he has recently
started selling things he owns in order
to upgrade to something more expensive
for example a new bow for hunting he
sold his old bow but the price of the
new one was over a thousand dollars
more than he got from the sale of his
old one he's an avid hunter and i want
to support and i want to be supportive
but the amount we have spent he has
spent in the last year on hunting gear
alone makes my palms sweaty he argues
that he is within the rules since he is
selling something he's already had but
the new purchase is always more
than what he gets from the sale am i
overreacting to this
um no you're not overreacting okay you
guys are still in debt
you're getting close to baby step three
but until you guys are out of baby step
three you are selling things in order to
get the cash from the sale to put
towards debt not to go
buy new stuff so no i don't think you're
overacting i think he's wrong in this um
he can
still hunt with the things he has
uh and still enjoy the hobby but you
don't have to go and and purchase new
stuff right now where you guys are at i
wouldn't i would wait till after baby
step three then he can upgrade some
stuff if he wants
but he needs to sell stuff in order to
put that money towards debt or towards
the emergency fund not to
buy something new that's the
exact correct tactical answer on what he
should be doing
the problem with this is not what he
should be doing the problem with this is
why
he's acting like a little boy and you're
acting like his mommy
he needs to man up
and decide that you and that the two of
you as a couple like two freaking adults
are trying to accomplish a goal together
and then he doesn't have to run whining
for permission to buy
a bow to go hunting
he needs to be participating in the
vision of the household
and once he decides that the two of you
are trying to accomplish a goal that's
worth it then it turns around the other
way and we start selling guns and
hunting gear and i'm a gun guy and i
have way too many of them
my wife is a purse woman and she has way
too many of them but none of those
things are getting in the way of our
future vision that we have for the
ramsey household as a couple
because that's more important than a
bunch of crap
purses and guns and bows and stuff that
we all collect
okay
so no it it's not about can how can i
how can i still be this thing and keep
the rules no you're going to keep he's
not i'm not breaking the rules no you're
not participating in the grown-up
discussion is the problem you need to
get your button gear i know but
participate in the grown-up discussion
yes but he's not the one asking the
question but that's the point i mean so
the point is kate it's not it's not can
we throw a blow a whistle with a striped
shirt and throw a flag he's out of
bounds he's out of bounds and not the
bow that he purchased
he's out of bounds in the fact that he
even wanted to purchase the bow because
he's completely not plugged into the
bigger picture the future the vision for
this house and this couple that's where
he's out of bounds
so that's where i'm throwing the flag
and that means that no you don't upgrade
your hunting equipment when you're in
debt
good god
no
and i'm not listen i'm all for you
getting your stuff guys i want you to go
do stuff i go do guy stuff all the time
i believe in it i think that's a big
deal and if you want to go hunting and
that's great
go hunting but you got a bow
and it wasn't a lack of a bow that
caused you to miss that last deer it was
the fact you didn't crawl up on it right
that was a problem it was you not the
it's not the arrow it's the guy shooting
it so there we go all right man he's
just i can't i think well
no i mean this is
this here i know i hear i hear you and i
agree i totally agree okay but listen
there are people all there are there are
millions of people right now and i bet
half of the or whatever half of them are
thinking that i have a spouse like that
though i have a my wife won't do it so
the point is you got to give you have to
talk about not the the discussion is not
about the bow yes the discussion is
about the vision and the lack of it but
if he will not then that's a marriage
issue that's really deep because you are
married to a little boy and not a man
you're married to a little princess and
not a woman
because you you step in beside your
spouse you put your shoulder in the
wheel and you lift to go do the things
that matter for your house
and instead of just like how little can
i get away with so she won't nag me
oh my god what are you in a sitcom i
mean go have like a re this is no no no
this lack of vision
uh from either spouse it doesn't matter
yeah you're right it's and so your my
point is it's not a it's not a hunting
gear problem
it's a vision problem and if you can't
solve that then you really at the core
of it you have a marriage problem
because i will never tell you in any
circumstance to babysit
your spouse
uh you know well you if you're married
to a woman like that you just have to
enjoy making money no you have to quit
being a wuss
and deal with the problems of her
behavior and you all look at each other
and go this is not causing us to win
and and she's just that way you're just
a wuss
deal with the stuff you know and and
it's not being mad at you but that you
cannot dance around it's like you know
how can i um how can i manage our
household in such a way to prepare for
divorce
you can't
you get divorced it's a freaking
financial nightmare
i mean marriage is grand divorce is 50
grand you can you can't half but do this
stuff because it's all this personal
finance is more personal than it is
finance yes all intertwined all
intertwined and for couples though you
know it's
you know a lot of people they don't even
have that discussion of what's the
vision of our of our of our household
where do we want to be like that's not a
that's not a normal discussion for a lot
of people so but the encouraging thing
is to sit down and and push into the
awkwardness like right like if you've
never had that discussion it's going to
be awkward it's going to be fun like
you're not going to know exactly what
you're doing but start the conversation
start talking about it because to your
point it's not just the money issue your
marriage changes when you guys get on
the same page and so there's something
about changing the marriage and the
outflow of that changed marriage comes
situations like a money situation that
you guys didn't work on together but but
a lot of people that even sitting down
and having that discussion that doesn't
have those don't those discussions don't
happen
in some households so
and but
you cannot fix
the hunting bow discussion with a
hunting bow answer
because the hunting bow discussion is
not the problem it's the symptom yep yep
the problem is we're not both being
grown-ups aimed at a big noble goal
that's big enough to cause me to put my
ch my items my selfish thing that i want
to decide for a few moments so that we
accomplish some bigger goals in my
marriage yeah and that's selflessness
that's a yeah and that's how they're
heard of marriage that's how marriages
get healed all the time in financial
peace university yep i mean i've had
people tell me for years you know we've
been to six marriage counselors and then
we went through fpu and it saved our
marriage because we force you to have a
vision for the future together
we're gonna be up in your grill
this is the ramsey shower
[Music]
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free stream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they really love and create actual
amazing relationships rachel cruz ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author my daughter is my co-host today
open phones a triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two 825-5225
andrew starts us off this hour in tampa
hi andrew how are you
good how are you pleasure speaking with
you you too sir how can we help
hey so my question is how do you split
ownership on a home um financially 50 50
if one person
makes pretty much substantially more
than the other
uh are you married
uh going to be in a year so that's kind
of why i'm you know i'm asking because
we're definitely gonna be looking if
you're married you don't split the
ownership both of you own it joint and
severally you own a hundred percent
understood
understood but i meant more financially
so
um let's just take the mortgage payment
oh uh the mortgage plan okay all right
so how do we budget who pays what of the
mortgage after we're married is that
your question
correct okay all right
yeah so andrew the way we we look at
that is that once the income hits the
bank account that you guys that it's
both your money i mean like both of you
um have the same amount of money it
doesn't matter who makes what
you guys are in a marriage and so you
are a team you are one
and we are all about combining your
finances and so that means if you know
your wife stays at home and you work and
your paycheck hits the bank account it's
as much hers as it is yours
um and vice versa so it's not a matter
of who brings it in it's just the fact
that you guys are one
and working as a team so yeah there's
not really a splitting the mortgage it's
uh we're going to pay it together it's
kind of the old-time marriage vows from
the book of common prayer okay for
richer for poor in sickness and in
health
and here's a phrase they don't ever use
anymore but in the old on in the old
marriage vows
unto thee
all my worldly goods i pledge
used to be part of the marriage vows in
sickness and health richer for poor unto
thee all my worldly goods i pledge and
so uh and the preacher says and now you
are
one
not and now you are a joint venture
let's figure out how to split this up
and so we're going to just take all the
money and put it in a pile and now that
pile of money is our money and we want
to accomplish our dreams our goals
address our fears with that pile of
money and how do we go about that one
thing we're going to do is obviously pay
the mortgage payment because we like to
live in this house another things we're
going to pay the light bill because we'd
like to have electricity we we
we we you change your pronouns when
you're married you become french we we
okay perfect and then do you believe in
separate checking and then a standard
account where both of you were on it
nope at all one account
don't need to
you don't need to because you're both
sharing everything there's no secrets
we're married we love each other we have
each other's best interest at heart we
want to cause the other person to win i
want to serve my wife she wants to serve
me we want to accomplish the things we
agree together that we want to
accomplish and we're going to do a
written plan a budget every month that
we both have a vote on she gets her
needs and desires addressed in that
discussion i get my needs and desires
addressed in that discussion they're
both on that piece of paper and so then
the money from the checking account goes
towards what we have previously agreed
on paper called a budget and so there's
no surprises
which andrew i and i hear you though
that i know that that this is kind of
weird advice because now the normal
um
way of going about money and marriage is
that yeah she has her checking account
you have yours you guys split the bills
and that's what it is but yeah but but
this is now we've been we've been living
together now for probably about two
years now engaged so it's it's at a
point where it's almost like
like you would call it roommates in a
way you are right now you are running
legally you are roommates today
correct legally after you're married
you're not anymore
it's all one but i mean and it really
pushes that discussion though andrew i
would i would encourage you guys if that
makes you uncomfortable for any reason
of like oh gosh we're going to share our
money start asking those questions why
does that make me uncomfortable is there
am i still wanting a part of my life
that i don't want to give up i mean
those are good questions not just for
your money but for your going into your
marriage because this is a
this is just a reflection of hey we're
going to share a bed we're going to
share our genetics running around with
little kids in the future like we're
going to share our life together and
that includes our money but if it makes
you if that has if you're hesitant or
she's hesitant on that i would push into
that asap because as a part of some of
your pre-marriage counseling yeah
so here's some data points that help
that help you with this as well that
that say that this is not just an
opinion okay we've done this i've done
this for 30 years and we've had 10
million people go through financial
peace university so it is more than an
opinion in that sense anecdotal evidence
there but the actual data says that the
number one cause of divorce is money
fights and money disagreements
and when we can get you to combine
your
income and combine your spending
decisions we're forcing you to combine
your dreams
to combine your fears
to combine
and if if our dreams include her going
and getting her masters
that's an hour dream we both want that
for her
right and that's money that's spent
directly on her but it's a part of our
dream okay if our dreams include uh you
getting a nice car that you've always
wanted then that's one of our dreams and
she's happy about that okay so the
you're combining your dreams you're by
forcing you to put the money together
and forcing you to make decisions
together we're forcing you to combine
your value system rather than having a
little secret life off to the side or a
lot of selfishness off to the other side
or something else so the number one
cause of divorce and
the second thing we found the other
piece of data in the largest study of
millionaires that's in the baby steps
millionaire's book that it was just a
number one the other day that i just did
um
of the millionaires that we studied uh
it was like 86 percent a tribute uh
they're becoming millionaires to the
fact that they were that their spouse
was on the journey with them
not they were dragging a reluctant
spouse or not they were over on the side
having their own little side hustle and
they just worked it out and their spouse
just was oblivious no they were on the
journey with them there's something
about both there's an old thing called
the uh the marriage what is that called
the marriage
uh it's a marriage advantage or
something like that that there's a there
was a study done about 25 years ago it's
probably dated now but it showed that
people that are married and have healthy
marriages they they live longer
they make more money
uh they're better in their careers
and so it was a marriage advantage
that's not the right phrase another word
for it i forget what it's called but
anyway that's what so all of that ties
but it all only works when you do this
combo thing yeah this combined
uh unified thing and you create a level
of unity in in your relationship and in
your marriage through the money lens
that nothing else will do yes and this
is all really big picture stuff but to
andrew like when you guys sit down and
do a budget you both get a line item in
the budget so like my husband
there's a winston line item there's a
rachel line item so i can still go to
target and shop or buy something online
i'm not like having to like go to him
with every single thing like i have
money to spend and but it's all coming
out of the same place it's all coming
out of the budget we agreed on it's
coming out of the same checking account
so it's not stripping away
your individual freedom you still have
the ability to like what you like and
spend where you want to spend but you're
doing it together
as one yeah it makes all the difference
in the world dude on your marriage and
on the probability of your building
wealth
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
a lot of people would rather spend their
weekend doing yard work or have a root
canal than talk about insurance but
here's the deal
if you don't take the time to learn
about insurance you're always going to
feel ripped off you know why you're
going to feel that way because you
probably are
getting ripped off
you make the wrong choices because you
don't know what you're doing that's
we all have this nagging thing about
insurance hey we think we think learning
about money should be simple our new
free
five-day guide to insurance called
confidence in your coverage it's free
it's a five-day guide to insurance
confidence in your coverage makes
learning about insurance quick practical
and even funny our own george campbell
does it you can be guaranteed you'll
have a chuckle in there
and it's really good it's really good
every day for five days george will walk
you through a new insurance topic very
quick very short very free
unpacking everything you need to know to
get the right coverage for you to top it
off we're doing a giveaway for the folks
to sign up at the end of the series you
might still have to do the yard work but
you'll at least know about insurance go
to ramseysolutions.com confidence and
sign up for the free five-day guide to
insurance confidence in your coverage
ramsey solutions.com
confidence kurt is in memphis hey kurt
welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave hey rachel thanks for having me
sure what's up um
well first i want to thank you so much
for all you've done thanks for the total
money makeover my wife and i have been
able to overcome some substantial
obstacles and eliminate 91 000 of debt
from way to go into 2020. awesome yes
sir
we uh we still have our mortgage but
we've experienced a ton of financial
freedom after eliminating that debt
after that debt we
started to save up our cash and we have
35 000 in an emergency fund and a high
yield savings account good for you um
but after that i got a little reckless
and i started putting our extra money
into an individual investment account
where i've been picking individual
stocks like alibaba chegg facebook
netflix
and
a bunch of those are down right now
but i do think they'll paint out long
term
um we have about 20 000 in that account
you know another ten thousand just
recently into series i bond
so my take-home pay is about or our
take-home pay it's about 6 100 a month
guarantee the family at least have a
thousand left over each month after
putting 15 percent into our retirement
uh the problem is both of our vehicles
have 165 000 miles on them and we're
considering having a third child and at
some point
a minivan is going to be needed i'm a
little bit worried about used car prices
and i want to wait as long as it can
but the money for that van that we have
saved up is in individual stocks right
now and the series i've on that extra 30
000.
i've considered whether we should use
our emergency phone for the car and just
let that stuff sit
i've got a job that's super stable
about as stable as it can get
i just i don't know what i should do
about that and whether i should start
putting my extra money towards a
mortgage or if i should start saving
that too in case this is this is exactly
why we tell people not to buy individual
stocks
right that's exactly why
i know and at this point i've done it
and they're sitting on my heart i get
that it's water under the bridge but the
the first part of this we have to
address is never do this again
it's not cool you did not beat the
system it kicked your butt up around
your neck
that's why you're calling her
okay
you violated a principle here of
diversification and you started screwing
around thinking you were too smart doing
single stocks and you got your butt
kicked
now first we got to own that
okay i'm not picking on you i just don't
want you to ever go back here again now
if you agree with that
and you say i'm never going back you
don't have to agree with me this is for
your purposes you got to decide this you
don't have to i'm not i don't need your
agreement you can decide you can do
whatever you want to do okay i'm just i
want to help you from this point forward
now that you're in the mess now if you
say okay i made a mistake because i took
too much risk playing with these single
stocks and i got my butt kicked and i'm
never doing that again now what do i do
well you get rid of them tomorrow
because every day you keep them it's
like you bought them again
meaning you think you still you're still
thinking you can hang on and win they're
going to be okay over time they're going
to be okay over time the stock market is
going to be okay over time not your
little portfolio
your little portfolio may still get its
butt kicked as the stock market recovers
i don't know
because you've got a handful of stocks
and you know
you're just
there's all kinds of studies that go the
individual person playing single stocks
can they it's like 90 of the time does
not even keep up with what the stock
market does
you always come in below the market
and it's because not because you're dumb
it's because you're not diversified
enough number one and number two
uh
that lack of safety then catches you
here uh because one or two little you
know you got six stocks two of them go
down it could take they can tank the
returns on the whole portfolio when you
got 200 stocks and five of them go down
or six of them go down it doesn't tank
the portfolio stock so what would i do
if i woke up in your shoes i would cash
out the eye bonds dumb investment i
would cash out the stocks dumb
investment immediately i'd put it in a
pile and i'd start linking thinking
about buying a car
okay
and stop doing this stuff that's what i
would do but you knew that you knew i
wouldn't do it when you called here you
already knew that the stuff we don't
tell you to do you know what would i do
if i woke up in bitcoin and bitcoin is
now what it's off 60 something percent
now from last september
so if you had a hundred thousand dollars
in there you've lost sixty thousand
dollars in bitcoin
and you bitcoin people been ragging me
threatened to burn my house down because
i said you were idiots
and and look how smart you are now
okay and it wasn't because i hate
bitcoin it's because i hate stuff that
is unproven because it kicks your butt
and now what would i do if i owned
bitcoin if i'd put a hundred thousand
dollars in bitcoin and i was you know
what what should you do you should get
out tomorrow because it may get better
it may get worse but it's still the same
stupid investment that it was last fall
it's just now you're you're in a
situation where warren buffett said when
the tide goes out you can tell who is
skinny dipping
when your stupid is stress tested it's
it comes up stupid
and i'm not fussing at you dude i'm just
fussing at all of us because i i did the
exact same stupid stuff when i was
in my 20s and i i put i put like 5 000
bucks in this gold thing this uh gold
futures thing this buddy of mine had a a
guy he had a guy he got you a guy as
soon as you've got a guy you know that
you're backing right about lose your
butt soon somebody says i got a guy that
he had hit gold he had picked out the
gold option uh mark and if you hit it
you'd take five thousand bucks and make
50 grand
okay and he had hit it 11 out of the
last 11 periods oh wow
he was a genius yeah until the 12th one
when i put in 5 000
and this genius right here so watch let
me tell you what happens if you don't
make the mark if you hit the mark the 5
becomes 50. if you don't make the mark
it becomes zero ah
zero you know it would be a function
no okay so on i have two thoughts real
quick kurt so yes cash out tomorrow buy
the minivan i would go with the honda
odyssey it's great fan from personal
experience uh but number two a funny
segment james would be all the the dumb
investments i've done like i was we had
a friend who will be unnamed about this
is my last this was probably so when
winston kind of first got married so
it's been 12 years or so so we had a
friend and he was
he was like hell but oh can i say that
you're too late you did
hell bent on the denarii
oh my losing value and he's like you
gotta get into the dinari market you
gotta get into this iraqi diner and and
it was like i don't know he put a couple
hundred bucks in he was like literally
this is gonna be three million in in a
year when the when the iraqi government
collapsed he had this whole like
political
he had figured it out strained through
it
and it wasn't there's the bitcoin of the
iraq war i get yeah yeah so anyways but
it did i i know yeah the dinar the iraqi
dinar yeah yeah you're gonna get it
funny segment for people to call in and
say hey here we need to do a stupid tax
hour again there you go stupid butt
stuff i have done that has cost me money
that's stupid tax
i'll lead off i'll tell you all the
stupid stuff i've done because i've done
a bunch of it that's why i'm so
passionate about this because it hurts
too much to me works it's hard for the
money and then it evaporate because i'm
stupid
i hate it when i'm stupid because it
costs money
i don't like it
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and serving christian
health cost sharing ministry chm has
shared medical expenses for its members
since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verses
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions and we invite you to join us
some of you are traveling if you stop
through nashville we're in franklin just
south of nashville the ramsey solutions
headquarters we got a big visitor center
free coffee free homemade chocolate chip
cookies and we have a debt free stage
where people come to do their debt-free
screams and brian and shannon join us on
that stage hey guys how are you hi hey
how you doing good to have you guys
where do you all live
elk mills maryland okay which is near
baltimore right yes okay cool good to
have you all how much debt have you paid
off
524 thousand dollars wow
how long did that take about five years
good for you guys way to go your range
of income during that time 160 and then
we ended at 195. cool what do y'all do
for a living
i'm a police officer
and i work in construction okay wow good
for you guys great incomes well done
five years 520 000. i'm going to guess
is that the mortgage we paid off our
head
[Applause]
looking at a couple of weird people oh
yeah i love it how old are you two
i'm 41. i'm 40. all right and you got a
paid four house yes what's this thing
worth
well the one we had we paid off was uh
we we sold one for about 300 and then
the other one we use that proceeds to to
pay off the other right the one you're
living in
and what's it worth that's about 200
right now good for you wow awesome fun
fun fun
excellent job guys how long you all been
married
15 years about that yeah yeah so what
happened five years ago that made you
decide hey we're gonna pay off our house
well
about six years ago brian started
getting sick
he had what is called a
and it started growing on the inside of
his ears kind of like a tumor growing
bigger and bigger and bigger
we didn't know about it and he went to
the doctor because he started getting
dizzy and falling off ladders
stuff like that at construction site
that's good not good
at that time we weren't living paycheck
to paycheck but we were
um
so when he started getting sick he
needed surgeries well without that
income things got real bad real quick
so i went to work one night and was
working patrol
and i was talking to my good buddy
justin bieber and when i say talking i
was sobbing
because
on one hand
i'm scared out of my mind and on the
other i'm angry
at him for getting sick
you want to talk about feeling pretty
humble and bad about yourself be angry
at your spouse for getting sick
so i ate a lot of humble pie um and then
we learned about your show and what you
do and he lent us the book the total
money makeover
which i read within oh my gosh two days
and then i went to him and i said we're
gonna do this and he's like all right
whatever yeah
yeah
and then what
and then we took the next five years uh
ate a lot of humble pie
made a lot more mistakes tons of them
and uh
so
the house we had two houses
um we have four beautiful children
and we said well we need a bigger house
they can't possibly share rooms that
would be child abuse
so we went and bought a really big house
but the way we did that was we took a
401k loan
which is the smartest thing ever right
it was a great idea yeah
so
they don't tell you when you take out
that loan that the irs is going to hunt
you down for more money right so we got
a 40 000 irs check well not check i wish
payments
and that knocked us off our feet
um so we have the two houses
the the one we didn't sell because we
bought it during the bubble
and so we kept that as a rental
and we rented it to people that brian
grew up with
and
we weren't the best of landlords because
we were just like okay go live there
we're not going to worry about it you do
whatever you need to do uh-oh which
meant they got 20 cats
lots of cats oh no
how'd you not just have to burn that
house oh my gracious i took about five
months gutting the whole thing
moved into it um what's what's crazy
about and i just got to speak on the
lord real quick here
so
they move out well we were going to
evict them but they just decided to move
out and we go in and it's just the worst
oh it smells so bad gosh
um and brian used our entire emergency
fund about thirty thousand dollars to
repair the house so you wanna talk about
feeling scared again right feeling
scared here we go again yeah we're gonna
sell the other house and work it's going
to be okay it's going to be okay
well the lord was so good to us that not
only when we sold the house did we make
enough to pay off the mortgage but he
gave us a 30 000 back yeah to put in our
emergency
so he's just been so good to us along
the way and brian your medical stuff
cleared
yeah it's ongoing but it's uh it's
sustainable now so it's just i go every
couple years to get a clean up kind of
thing and it's nothing like it was
before
and so that allows you to get back to
work then obviously all these years yeah
well yeah but i'm not scared anymore now
yeah
we're mad at him about it
he can go ahead and heal he's gonna
i use it as a vacation
this is my little time off yeah oh man
okay so when shannon is like no okay i'm
reading this book i'm doing it i'm doing
it she made the comment like and brian
was like okay okay so how was the
journey for you brian if she's like all
pumped up and ready to go yeah
i had a uh i just bought an a a big
truck we wanted to pull the a fancy
camper that we bought so i had this nice
truck and yeah she's like i think we got
to sell it and
well i had to bring it up like it was
his idea
you know like oh don't you think we
should do this and
yeah he he let us sell it yes so you
guys together though in five years like
how is marriage different would you say
we used to call it the friday night
fights she would come up
and like oh you got to spend your money
this way that way and i'm like well you
can tell me how i'm going to spend my
money i'm going to spare if you're a cop
or not you're going to tell me this man
yeah so we just started uh you know kind
of doing everything the right way and
and that's where it started once you
started getting them principles in line
i was able to get in line on that sure
sure and you guys working more as a team
than ever before that's amazing yeah i
think it really helped the marriage out
a lot yes whoa whoa whoa
a lot for me
no but um we now teach financial peace
university at our church at nottingham
missionary baptist church
and it's it's incredible to see where we
came from
and i mean we still make mistakes like
that's that's you know i thought i'd be
a millionaire by now dave like where's
the money right but we still don't know
you know god willing but it's cool to
share those mistakes with others because
we've been teaching fpu for what two
three years now and no one has made as
many mistakes as we have so that's kind
of cool where we can just share that you
are infinitely qualified yes to lead fbu
yeah and make great coordinators
coordinators that are perfect are lousy
coordinators
well we're the lousiest yeah no you're
you're the imperfect you're the perfect
coordinator so yeah that's great way to
go you guys so yeah you're well on your
way you got a paid for house it's worth
a couple hundred thousand you're making
a couple of hundred a year got no bills
in the world what's the first big thing
you're gonna do to celebrate now we're
here yeah we're doing this this is a
celebration we have been counting down
the days uh to come do this stand on
your stage and thank you personally for
what you've done
for our family uh it's just been
incredible thank you so much because
this is not easy you're going against
the culture you're telling people what
they should be doing and nobody wants to
hear that you know they don't want to
they don't want to hear good sound
advice or
what we should be doing but you've been
on patrol you know the culture of
something needs to be gone against oh my
gracious yeah
we're fighting a
battle outside wild it's wild yeah and
so common sense has got to be prevailing
and you guys are just perfect i love you
you're heroes well thank you well done
i'm so proud of you very very cool thank
you very cool we got a copy of baby
steps millionaires for you that's the
next chapter in your story for sure copy
a total money makeover you'll give that
away to one of your fpu attendees for
sure and we'll give you an fpu
membership you can give that away to
somebody that you've got somebody
somewhere
that you're talking to on patrol that's
crying about something like you were and
you'll be able to help them well that's
the best part dave is like i see a lot
of people in really bad spots and being
able to help them yeah you know and
showing them a little bit of god yeah
all right let's bring the kiddos up come
on and get them into the deal allison
nice brielle brielle brielle camille and
joseph all from the baltimore maryland
area with brian and shannon to 524
thousand paid off in five years count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream
three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
they are fun
way to go you guys they're neat i mean
that makes you just glad that ladies out
there on patrol you know glad he's in
the construction business look great
moms and dads husbands and wives good
stuff
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author is my co-host today open phones
at triple eight eight two five five
two two five laura is with us in alaska
hi laura welcome to the ramsey show
hello dave and rachel thank you for
taking my call sure what's up
um uh my question today is uh how to
best support my husband through a career
change um
he was a framer in college uh mostly
working for his father's residential
contractor business
but he's been in banking for the past
seven years and um he's he's trying to
change his careers to go
back to being um like a project manager
or a residential contractor
and uh so far in the last like three
four months um we've put about two
thousand dollars into classes and exams
and his next exam um tries uh is next
week um he doesn't want a huge pay cut
right now he's making between
eighty and a hundred thousand a year
with uh bonuses um so so he doesn't want
like to start over with his career
now that he's been doing this a while um
and and it's just kind of a
it's just kind of led to a lot of
it's just a lot of angst i guess but um
i guess my question is like how to best
support him through that uh through all
of this big change that's happening
because he will his income go down with
the new job
um so
like if
starting a whole new business as a
residential contractor first needs a
license and then he needs clients and uh
it's hard to get a loan without
experience like he's looked into getting
a loan for like
a contract loan um
for for building a house for someone but
so he wants to um get credit cards and
get more credit and be able to build a
house he
sold his fancy truck and and bought a a
cheaper truck and so we have 40 000
saved for a plot of land but
i guess it's just kind of a it's kind of
an unclear direction of how to start a
business and
and and he knows how to do all that it's
just um
it's going to be hard because he like to
quit his job that makes 80 000 to start
a business that potentially might not
make anything for a year or two and um
it's just
i guess it's just kind of an unclear
path and all those kind of stuff well
and part of the problem is it is a clear
path it's just a bad one and that's part
of what's bothering him and you
because what you're describing to me is
ultra high risk
you're setting yourself up for
bankruptcy
so no you don't need to do what you're
doing i would recommend not doing his
path
um
hold on hold on hold on i do want him to
go be a residential contractor
and i do want him to make this change
i do not want him building a house for
someone else with him with money he
borrowed
uh lots of contractors
do cost plus
or even
a profit margin agreement whichever it
is and they're very similar
uh and so if i got ready to build a
house i could put up the money
and hire a contractor
and they use my money to build my house
and he makes a profit
that is a normal arrangement in custom
home building
you don't need to go into debt to build
a house for somebody else they should
have the money
and if they don't have the money they
can go get a construction loan and if
your husband has a contractor's license
in the state of arkansas the bank will
loan them the money against a set of
plans an appraisal and then and you're
able to draw on the construction loan as
as percentages of completion on the
product on the house are done in no case
is your husband or you on the debt the
individual building that is going to end
up owning the house goes and gets the
construction loan and then the draw
comes out and when the draw comes out
it's to pay the lumber bill and to pay
the contractor a percentage of his
profit because we reached the 50 mark or
the 25 mark or whatever
and that's it's laid out in a normal
construction draw
program it's typically done for instance
after the foundation is in is one draw
after the framing package is up is
another draw uh those are typical very
i've been around this business my whole
life and been in it my whole life so
but there's no reason for you to have to
go borrow money to buy a plot of land to
build something on that is not a good
way to do this and in the meantime i
would start doing a bunch of renovations
and build decks and build other things
on the side as a side hustle and get my
volume up and get my customer base up
before i quit
because in order to build a custom home
he's gonna have to be full-time
yes definitely i've i've sent him jobs
like carpenter jobs and and other things
but he he really doesn't want to take a
pay cut like in between like i want him
to do that as a side hustle
evening yeah no pay cut
put some guys up put some guys on the
job building the deck go by and see them
before work and after work and check
them on the weekends
and sub it's about to work
with his with his contractor's license
do some renovations same way but he does
not have to be on the job all day long
on these small projects
and there's no pay cut involved because
he's still got his banker job
until he gets his income up and gets
enough
and he gets two or three custom houses
lined up and okay we're getting ready to
break ground this month on one next
month on another next month on another
and you've got those under contract
meaning the the people building the
house have signed a contract with you to
be their contractor now you've got
business that you can quit a based on
okay but you don't have to go into debt
to do this and you don't have to quit
cold turkey to go do this
okay
cool i i will i will let him know okay
and i i can be very supportive of all
that because i think he could actually
make about double what he's making now
with his move i think he's going to make
more and do stuff he loves
and he kind of cut his teeth on the
business he grew up in the business but
guys who go out and just start spec
building as we're heading into a
recession the ones that get their butts
kicked
yeah
yeah and and you and you feel that angst
laura like even when you were asking the
question i could hear it in your voice
you weren't sure what to be nervous
about but you just knew it wasn't right
yeah it's it
yeah yeah i love him i want him to win i
don't want to i don't want to kill his
dream but i'm feeling like a nightmare
and does is he would he receive this
like if you kind of walked through this
call
um of just different ideas versus i'm
gonna quit tomorrow and go into debt to
build a house and all that like
what is his what's his level of um
comfortable is he comfortable in his
plan
um
i don't i don't fully think
he is he um
it's this sounds bad but dave ramsey's
been a bit of a curse word in our in our
you know ten month marriage and like i
got i i got myself out of debt he paid
for the wedding with cash
and uh but we both you know we're not on
a strict budget but we have shared bank
account it's just kind of um it's just
been i don't know a little tense with
with all of this change and underneath
all of it is just kind of that he's just
really unhappy with his current career
choice and it's just brought a lot of
frustration i'm completely in agreement
with him i would much rather build
houses and be a banker
it just sounds like a whole lot more fun
to me
so i'm totally i'm totally supportive of
his dream but here's the thing you can
always do a dream
with improper steps and and turn it into
a nightmare and that's what i don't want
for him or for you
and laura too i would i would kind of
push into this because you guys have
been married 10 months
it kind of feels like a little bit of
shaky foundation of like we're not we're
on the same page but we're not here and
it's this and i'm kind of tiptoeing
around different stuff i mean you guys
kind of just need to have uh over dinner
this weekend just say hey
i just need to say out loud the things
that i'm thinking and feeling and i want
you to hear them and it takes courage to
do that but for him to hear that and you
guys start these kind of conversations
because tiptoeing around the issues
is starting out a terrible habit for
marriage
are you all like 26
uh we're we're
30 and 31. okay yeah because here
here's what
i'm old so when someone says to me how
can i be supportive of my husband and
then they lay out all of the things that
he's doing that don't feel right
that's code for i think this is a really
stupid idea how can i really tell him
that and still love him
and still and still want him to go
beyond
it's code for you know you don't really
want to be supportive of him doing
cocaine you know you don't
how can i be supportive of my husband
while he does a little cocaine no you
can't you can't do that that's you're
not supportive of that
and it's sweet but it's just wrong you
know no i my wife does not support me
and things that she thinks is crazy but
you can be respectful in the
conversation absolutely honest where you
are lord to him i think is one of the
biggest gifts you will give him
no obligation to support things that
violate your
beliefs and your common sense
don't support those because you're going
down with the ship you're on the ship
you know both of you are on it together
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
this is the ramsey show where we help
people build wealth
do work that they really love and create
actual amazing relationships
open phones here at
825-5225 my co-host today is rachel cruz
ramsey personality number one
best-selling author and my daughter open
phones at
eight two five five two two five charles
is in green bay wisconsin hey charles
welcome to the ramsey show
mr ramsey and mrs cruz it's truly an
honor to speak with you you too sir
what's up
okay i want to be rare people without
paying any stupid tax so my question is
i make about 150 000 a year combined
income with my wife
we have 65 000 left to pay on the
mortgage that's our only debt
um i started a new job about six months
ago
and july 1st is when i can start
investing so in the meantime i've been
tripling and quadrupling my payments my
mortgage payments
so my question is should i
stop that
and
keep uh and invest and then spend or
whatever or
should i
start investing also we have
40 000 in savings
and it's emergency fund and when my
mortgage gets down to 40 000
so i just pay it off
i know my expenses will go down without
having a mortgage i don't know what to
do like right about there
yeah it's all
great questions charles so
um
currently i would say when you can start
investing
into your company's 401k then i would
back down the mortgage payments and pay
up to 15 of your income and i would be
putting that into retirement and then
anything else that you have
throw it at the house
but when you guys get down to that 40
000 i would not empty your emergency
fund you can maybe a little bit if you
don't need that all forty thousand for
three to six months worth of expenses
um
you could use some of that to pay off
the mortgage faster if you don't need
all forty um but i would um be investing
that fifteen
um which would mean probably backing
down your mortgage payment
yeah 15
we teach people to do baby steps four
five and six simultaneously four is 15
of your income into retirement five is
kids college doing something in the kids
college if you have kids it's
appropriate beyond that everything you
can find you throw at the mortgage so
yes it is going to reduce
the amount that you're able to put on
the mortgage but you're still making a
plenty of money to get this mortgage
knocked out and you got a tiny little
mortgage so you're gonna knock it out
you're gonna be just fine but no i would
and i'm with rachel i would not clean
out the emergency fund but if you want
to say hey i don't need 40 000 when the
house is paid off i need 25 000. so i'm
going to take 15 of it and throw it at
the mortgage right now that gets it down
to 50 and we're just going to attack
this thing with a vengeance
beyond but i would start my fifteen
percent of my income into retirement um
uh
you know you're gonna get whatever match
you get put it into roth 401k into good
growth stock mutual funds stock market's
down so it's on sale it's a great time
to be investing
and while the market's down it's just a
wonderful time and so uh you know
the bad thing about
slow economic times as the stock market
goes down the great thing about slow
economic times is the stock market goes
down and so it's a great time to invest
and yeah i wouldn't miss out on that i
would be doing that but only 15 not 20
not 26 percent 15
no more everything else goes on the
house good questions charles henry's
with us henry is in albuquerque new
mexico hi henry how are you
i'm great thank you hi dave hi rachel
thank you for taking my call sure um i
appreciate all you do um i am 56 years
old and i recently last week sold um an
investment property that i had and it
sold for 497 000 um with all the closing
costs and credits and whatnot basically
i had 450 000 left over with that i paid
off um
a home equity line of credit that i have
on on the home where i actually live and
i put 35 000 towards the mortgage and
that leaves a balance on the mortgage of
65 thousand that's my only debt i have
an emergency fund for three months
and i have about eighty thousand dollars
in uh retirement accounts you did not
hold back the money for the capital
gains tax
uh i have 350 000. my thought was to put
at least 50 000 on the site for the
capital gains and then any um
uh i guess depreciation or whatever i
thought you put it all on the mortgage
already
i put 35 000 which brought my
thousand okay and mortgage still got but
after you did all those things you got
350 000 you're sitting on
i have 350 000 and i have a 65 000 um
dollar outstanding mortgage yeah so
write a check and pay off your mortgage
today
gotcha good good job man you're gonna
have some capital gains though do you
know what your adjusted basis was on the
property i don't i'm actually meeting
with my accountant to like discuss that
so i'm not sure have him calculate your
capital gains now
because it's 15 of your gain and you've
owned this property for how long you've
been had it as a rental
yeah i've had it for 10 years so i don't
fall within an exception i i haven't
lived there and no i'm not worried about
that i was trying to figure out how much
you depreciated it because you've
depreciated it every year
and uh so uh you know as you've written
it off
uh all of this is not gonna be gained
but a lot of it is so you probably i'm
gonna give you a guess
let's say you got a 300 000
probably that much at least
okay uh 300 and like 20 gain i think it
was yeah yeah if you got a 300 no i'm
talking about the gain of your sale
price minus your expenses minus your
adjusted basis
which is your original basis minus the
depreciation that you took okay so
you've got the adjusted basis that's how
you calculate the gain now i'm going to
guess based on the fact you've held it
10 years and you've depreciated it that
you're that you got probably got a 300
000 gain or so which is going to be
about a 45 000 tax bill at 15
gotcha so but let him calculate it
exactly if he says it's 62 426 dollars
since 65 000 aside then pay you pay off
your mortgage anyway you're not going to
have so much gain you can't pay the
mortgage so go and pay off the mortgage
but set your capital gains aside and
then beyond that now you've got all this
money free and clear you got no other
debt right
no other debt i do have two children
though um and i have about 58 000
um in um a 529. so 29 000 each but i
think my older son who's uh 16 will not
be going to college so
um yeah yeah sorry i mean you got that
money free just to invest and to do some
generosity with it and if it's in an
investment in your name and you need it
for a kid you can always get to it right
right yeah so yeah then i would sit down
with the smartvestor pro after you've
set your money aside for capital gains
to start thinking about how you're going
to invest the balance because it sounds
like it's
you're gonna have a couple hundred
thousand bucks left
after capital gains and mortgages paid
still to do something with uh you may
want to upgrade a car you may want to
take your wife on trip she probably
deserves it or whatever it is you want
to do that something sweet and fun and
nice
and probably want to do some of those
kinds of things and then sit down with
your smart vista pro to do some
investing if you don't have someone in
your corner click smart fester at ramsey
solutions we'll hook up with the people
we recommend
we're not in that business but these are
people that do the things we teach and
they'll help you to execute these ideas
these strategies
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the ramsey show rachel cruz
ramsey personality is my co-host today a
lot of you are thinking about moving
right now
that's awesome moving is exciting
and there's a lot of real things to talk
about when you talk about moving if
you're moving across the country across
town you're going to be facing some
sky-high home prices
interest rates are up
and the challenge of finding experienced
pros that you can trust
when it comes to something as important
as buying a home you don't use your
friend's cousin
who just got their license or your uncle
charlie or henrietta down at the church
that just got her license you get a
simple google search you know you just
randomly drop in on a real estate agent
that's not a good way to pick out
somebody to sell your largest asset or
help you purchase your largest asset you
should be able to find high caliber pros
that you can rely on whether you're
moving from florida to alaska no matter
where you're moving and we have vetted
thousands of real estate agents around
the country and we've got the high
octane high protein people who sell a
lot of houses that can help you they're
ramsey trusted agents they're they're
our endorsed local providers and they've
earned our seal of approval they
prioritize you
over just getting a commission check
they want you
to have a
incredible home buying home selling
experience go to ramseysolutions.com
agent find the best agents across the
country that's ramsey solutions.com
agent you know rachel you and i were
talking about real estate a little bit
the other day on the air when you were
on here last
and um
i keep digging into what's happening
with the market
there's a little bit of a weird thing
happening with the bad economic news out
on inflation and gas prices and now
interest rates continuing to climb
and
now pretty much the announcement that we
probably are heading into
the second quarter of uh an economic
shrinkage called a recession
uh when the total goods and services the
gross domestic product shrinks two
quarters in a row that's called a
recession
and so uh when it's put on the news it's
called a recession you're gonna die
but that's not really what it is it's
just you know it's a recession it just
means it receded that's all it means
nothing to panic over
but you add with the summertime came and
a lot of people
and i'm talking to some of you out there
right now
you like uh
take a vacation on adulthood
during the summer
like you can go do anything you want to
do stupid and you'll deal with it in the
fall and i'm not going to worry about
buying a house or selling a house and
i'm just going to go on vacation
and i'm going to spend money i don't
have and i'm not going to deal with this
stuff it's summer i'm putting my life in
neutral and i'm going to let it get a
little bit worse before i deal with it
and there's a lot of that
it's kind of a
i guess it's built into us as little
kids we go to school and we get off for
the summer and now people when we're
adults we think we can get off for the
summer yeah and we don't have to you
know and so
church attendance goes down
generosity goes down
gym
membership gym atten attending the gym
to work out goes down
it's not just because it's pretty
outside it's because you're freaking
laying around okay so uh
or you're home with the kids yeah well
or whatever there's school and you don't
have that there's already there's this
there's this mental thing yeah there's a
check out i get that so that's adding to
this real estate market stuff hmm
because people aren't jumping up and
down to go buy hey because they're all
frantic about buying a house then all of
a sudden they go on vacation
mentally yeah and emotionally yes and so
here's the thing i want to tell you guys
right now this is an unusual market
because we're kind of at this midpoint
there's like a tipping point thing going
on it's like it's getting ready to go
and flip
uh it's not it's not going to flip quick
but we're at this moment in time and i
would say for the next six months this
is going to be true
that and you can't usually say this
is what i'm saying
right now
is a the best time to buy a house
in the next five years
right now
and here's why
okay prices are not going to go down
some of you are saying well i'm going to
wait for prices to come down you're
you're not going to get them yeah
they're not coming down yeah okay
they're going to go up slower
but they're not going to go down
they may not go up hardly at all but
they're not going to go down
and so five years from today houses are
going to be more expensive this is as
cheap as it's going to be five years in
the next five years so this is the best
price right now if you're going to buy a
house well interest rates are up buy the
house if interest rates come back down
refinance yeah but don't not buy
waiting on interest rates to come down
just refinance the mortgage of interest
rates come down this is the best time to
buy a house in the next five years and
here's what's weird
this is also the best time to sell a
house
in the next five years
why because we still
have
semblance of the crazy white hot market
around
and it's really just vibrating it's
still really
like if you're a seller you really have
a real hot commodity right now you got a
nice house you put on the market it'll
go and it'll go for a really good price
right now
and and it may not be that way six
months from now
the market may slow down enough that as
a seller you may have to sit on a house
for a while to get a good price out of
it yeah now i don't think you're gonna
lose money five years from now
but if you're if you got a i was talking
with a friend of mine um
last night that had a
a really big expensive property that uh
he sold a farm he sold it and uh he said
because this was the best time
in the next five years to get rid of
that that farm he goes this i didn't
really i didn't have to sell it didn't
need to sell it but it was timing the
market that this is a great it's an
unusual statement when you can say this
is the best time to sell in the next
five years and this is the best time to
buy i know because it's so expensive
still yeah do you know what i mean so
but it's not going to get cheaper yeah
yeah it's not going to get cheaper yes
it's not get you you can't wait on it to
get cheaper because it's not going to i
really do believe that and what causes
right
what causes real estate to go down is
this a stupid question i'm saying
when supply
exceeds demand to go yes but in the
history of real estate
there's only one time in the last
hundred years that it went down okay
ever period
so year after year and interest rates
always it's gone up except for the rest
of 1992 when the interest rates went to
19 18 fixed the prices did not go down
now the sales came to a screeching halt
yeah people quit buying because they
couldn't afford to pay payments on a 15
mortgage but uh i mean we were i was
selling real estate at the time i was in
my early 20s selling real estate trying
to make a living doing i was in college
selling real estate i sold some houses
and you know 15 16 17 fixed rate market
but some of them were for cash people
had money um it was a good time to buy
at that time but the so it's not a
bubble well we all just went through the
last year of real estate or however long
that has just been insane it's not going
to pop and everything's going to go
down because i've heard people say it's
not a bubble that that like you know in
pockets of america because of the rush
you know to states with no income tax of
florida tennessee right that that these
those are what that's done is it
artificially drove the price up faster
so we like we saw in 2020 prices go up
32 nationwide on real estate i mean my
god insane yeah okay and this year we're
predicting seven percent
all right so we're going to see and
that's a pretty good rate seven percent
is not a bad goal every time it goes up
seven percent a year while you own it
for 30 years you're gonna be rich off
your house okay so uh it's not a bad
thing but what what the the bubble
that is there is not on the actual price
itself the bubble is on the rate of
increase
that 32
is not that bubble is going to burst it
already has yeah yeah it's just not all
the way down yet and so you're what's
gonna happen is the rate of increase is
different than the price
how fast they're going up
that is a bubble
that bubble is gone it's gonna burst but
they're not gonna i don't because we all
the data we have shows that there is
this extreme shortage of housing
and new housing starts are not coming up
fast enough to offset it yeah so we're
not going to have an oversupply i just
wonder though like the houses like i
just think about even in our
neighborhood you know for what they're
going for like the a new build what it's
going where is it it's insane but you
think you can still get that price it's
just emotional they will still get that
price though yeah they will
yeah
they will the house that sold for two
million dollars
uh two months ago
five years from now will sell for more
than two million dollars yeah but i'm
saying can they get it will they get a
year from now a year from now it won't
be 1.8 it'll be 2.1
yeah it's not going to go down
but it's not there may not be it may not
be as easy to sell it all that this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author my co-host today
jared is with us jared's in midland
michigan hi jared how are you
good sir how are you better than i
deserve what's up
so uh me and my fiance are getting
married here soon in july um and we she
just graduated college with a nursing
degree and i've got a house that i
bought before we met
um i also have a new truck and she has a
new car
so we together we have about 330 000 in
debt
um we both just started jobs where we're
making decent money um we gross about 90
000 a year
and i guess we were just kind of
wondering
um
you know coming up on our wedding and
hopefully having kids here shortly in
the next year or two um how we can kind
of prepare for
a solid foundation financially
yeah well congratulations on the on the
engagement the wedding coming up so
out of the 330 of
debt what is what's in the cars and
what's in the student loans
so my house i owe about a hundred
thousand on
um uh her student loans are about 170.
my uh my truck's 33 her car is 12.
so okay
holy crap
okay yeah
how old are you guys
i'm 25 she's 26. okay so when you add
that up does it kind of scare the crud
out of you
oh absolutely what about her
oh yeah probably her more than me good
okay because i don't want you to be
debilitated by fear but i want you to be
afraid enough to do something about it
so that's good
okay
is she in the nursing position you think
she's going to be in long term or is
this just like a stepping stone because
of
her degree i think she'll stay there
so what she really enjoys the work that
she does
she's
she makes about
uh
59 000 a year and you make 30
no net she makes like 59. um take home
probably like 41 ish and i may take home
like 40. okay i thought you said 90
gross
of course yeah
yeah she makes like 41. i make like 48.
gross 90 net 90 you meant 19. that's
what your take-home pay
take home yeah sorry yeah 90 net not 90
gross so you're making about 130 110
okay good
yeah all right good so good uh and what
do you do jared
i'm a millwright
okay good
good all right
well the good news is in both of your
cases you probably can pick up some
extra hours that are very very
profitable hours
oot and both of these things pays very
well we don't want to do that long term
and we don't want to do it too much in
your first year of marriage
but uh we want to do it strategically to
be able to exit to be able to get rid of
these debts i'm not worried about the
house the student loan is a serious
mountain the trucks probably under the
heading of sold
okay because you guys got to clean this
mess up the faster you're out of debt
everything but the house the faster
you're gonna have amazing peace in this
household because you're you know you're
gonna be making over a hundred thousand
dollars a year with no payments but a
hundred thousand dollar house payment
yeah that's a really good place to be in
at 25 years old it's not gonna be 25
it's gonna be 27 it's gonna take you two
years to clean this up
or more
but the 170 is a big number
and so what i always look at
mathematically that gives me uh great
hope is the size of the shovel you have
your income
household income versus the size of the
hole you're in
uh and and so you're in a really big
hole
but you got a good shovel
and so i'm not panicking looking at the
math okay
but i do know you guys got two
to three years of beans and rice
no life ahead of you to clean this mess
up
and i personally wouldn't try to ride a
33 000 truck through that i'd ride a an
8 000 truck through that
okay how much you can sell it for jarrah
do you know
um
probably 40 42 yeah they give you enough
combine of the car for cash and get rid
of a truck payment that's 700 bucks a
month right that would be huge that
would be huge sure yeah
that moves the needle and then then you
list your debts smallest to largest that
would just leave her car and the student
loans and we begin to attack them get
her car knocked out and then we begin to
attack these student loans with a
vengeance and don't go into debt for the
wedding jared don't continue to dig in
that hole
no our parents are out oh awesome pretty
much cash flow on the left that's great
very grateful for that that's awesome um
so
she has an option to consolidate her
student loans which would drop her it'd
go from a i think a 30 year to a 15 year
but it would take it from like a two
thousand dollar monthly payment to a
fifteen hundred dollar monthly payment
that's wise doesn't matter what i'm
concerned about here is the interest
rate what's it do to the interest rate
uh
nine or ten percent before 10 to four
percent yeah the lower interest rate is
excellent
15 years doesn't matter because you're
going to pay them off in three years
you're going to be 100 debt free in
three years
okay
well so the other thing i was thinking
um her if she makes her minimum payment
on her student loans for 10 years her
work will pay it off is that we're not
writing that out and having absolutely
not nope okay no her work won't pay it
off you're talking about the federal
government paying it off and they have
not been doing that there's a 97
turn down rate on that plan it is a
failure okay so no we don't we don't let
somebody else clean up your deal you
guys got to go clean this mess up and
here's the thing a little bit of ot on
both of you we can kick this thing
without you without you completely
giving up your your newlywed year okay
but you can kick your income up another
50 grand pretty easy
and that's where i'm getting these
numbers okay
and so between the two of you and just
strategically pick some er work on the
weekends for her or something like that
you pick up some just some straight old
ot i'm sure it's available to you right
now because everything's gearing back up
no pun intended in your case but the uh
uh
but the you know the uh you guys are in
you got great careers because you got a
lot of opportunity here to clean the
mess up and so but here's the thing
there's a direct correlation by how
intensely you attack this
and how fast you get out number one and
if you get out at all number two
the probability of completing it
is tied to your intensity and
the
speed at which you complete it being
debt-free it
um is tied to your intensity so i want
you guys to sit down have a very
detailed plan and attack this we're
going to help you we're going to give
you financial peace university as a
wedding gift okay
free oh thank you and the two of you
that's awesome yeah the two of you go
through that and um
that's good pre-marriage counseling it's
going to teach you to work together as a
team to accomplish a goal it's gonna be
great for your relationship anyway but
it's also gonna
normalize this process because what
you're getting ready to do
none of your friends are gonna be doing
they think you're gonna think you joined
a cult
yeah sure
i mean you sold your truck have you lost
your mind you know that kind of stuff
let me tell you jared you guys together
like
just to speak even more on that
sacrifice like this is the time to do it
as newlyweds before kids like if you
have the bandwidth to do it do it do it
now because you're gonna fast forward in
four years and you're gonna have a baby
on the way you guys are gonna have no
payments and the the level of peace that
you will have so much more
doing it now
versus waiting it out because i mean we
talked to so many people are getting out
there and they have the kit and they
have kids and they're doing it and it
absolutely can be done but god they look
back like why didn't we start this
sooner so the sooner you guys can do
this the more intense you can do it and
shake hands and say okay we're in it we
are in it and we're going to complain
together we're going to be in it
together we're going to celebrate
together we'll be tired we're retired
together but like this is our journey
and two what it will do for your
marriage you guys working on the same
team with a huge goal like this and to
accomplish that your first couple years
of marriage is it will do so much for
you guys i mean it will it will it will
unite you guys in a whole other way
versus if you kind of just were like and
we're okay with it it's fine and just go
through life so there's there's a lot of
pros here you guys have you said you're
25 right
yes sir okay so when you're 30 here's
what it's going to look like if you do
this
you're going to be making without
overtime
150 to 170 000 a year
you're gonna have no payments
except a little bit of a house payment
left and
you may even have it paid off
and you're going to have 40 or 50 000 in
the bank
and you're going to have learned to work
together you're going to go on a great
vacation you're going to be on your way
you're driving that truck again jared
exactly you're gonna be on your way to
being a millionaire in no time that's
what five years from now looks like but
you got some hills to climb between now
and then hold on uh we'll have austin
pick up get you guys signed up for our
gift of financial peace university
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day proverbs 4 26
watch the path of your feet
and all your ways will be established
dolly parton said if you don't like the
road you're walking start paving another
one love it way to go miss dolly liz is
with us liz is in palm springs hi liz
welcome to the ramsey show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
sure what's up
um so i'm graduating college uh with my
bachelor's in psych i'm 23
and i'm graduating this saturday and i'm
kind of
wondering if you like what you think i
should do in terms of i
don't like my home situation i really
really want to move out
but i'm 13 000
in debt um
so i'm not sure if i should tackle my
debt first before moving out or if i
should
get an apartment first um
do you was you have a job lined up
um i'm looking for jobs i have one
that's lined up but the pay is only
twenty dollars an hour
okay
how much would you be working
um i'd be working 40 hours a week four
days working
yeah
um well i think it's just in 13 000 in
student loans
or it's 10 000 student loans and 3 000
in credit card debt okay okay
um
yeah i mean i still think to be able to
be out on your own um
for sure is a possibility i mean i would
be looking at your job you need to look
at your budget and figure out okay how
much is going to be your take-home pay
you want to make sure you rent somewhere
that's no more than 25 of your take-home
pay but i would not go buy a house i
would go rent an apartment
but i think it's totally feasible yes
for you um to get out what's the
situation
what makes you want to want to leave
um so we moved in with my brother um
just um stuff happened we moved in my
brother but the thing is that he's
always bringing home girls he's he's
very um kind of verbally abusive to me
and my mom is as well so
i really want to move out and but the
problem is that if i were to find an
apartment it wouldn't be 25 um just
because like rent around here and even
in cities around is like 1 500 for like
one person
so i'm
i'm kind of just stuck i don't want to
get an apartment i can't afford but then
i don't want to work like
two jobs and
i mean if i have to i will but i just
feel like
i can't afford it you have to
until you get a better job you're going
to be working two or three jobs
right yeah you're broke
and 20 and 20 an hour doesn't cut it in
palm springs
i know
that's what you're saying and i don't
disagree with you so you may be moving
to a different city too
i mean palm springs is not exactly
cheapville
no
this is like one of the most expensive
areas in the united states
yeah it's not designed for people it's
not the the economics there are not
designed for people to make 20 bucks an
hour
right yeah
so here's the question so there's a
couple of variables here all right
location
the city you live in is a variable
uh your income
what you make per hour
is a variable you found one job at
twenty dollars let's go find one at 40.
let's go find one for 40.
let's use your degree use your psych
degree get into some marketing
get into something use that psych degree
that where it has value where you
understand human nature and you're
plugging in
and the other variable is the amount of
hours you work
and so it probably is that for the next
three years you're going to work a lot
more than 40 hours
and it's there's a possibility you're
doing that in a different city
and there's a possibility a strong
possibility you need to look for a
better job because you haven't found the
best one yet
you can make 20 an hour stocking shelves
at freaking target
so you haven't found the best job yet
okay
agreed
yeah okay yeah
so all of that to combined sets you free
from a toxic situation
hours worked
better pay per hour
and a possible geography change to an
area that's more affordable the
combination of those three variables
however you dial them in
uh puts you out in the wild wild west
kiddo you're out here in the big big
girl world now but you're out of the
toxic mess the sewage that is your
family
right yeah and you need to be free from
that don't you
yeah and it's worth 80 hours a week work
for two years to get free from it
right yeah i agree yeah yeah
that's what the tears are
you need some freedom
but it's scary isn't it
yeah yeah but here's the thing you
needing this freedom does not mean a
fifteen hundred dollar apartment works
on a twenty dollar an hour forty hour a
week it doesn't that math doesn't work
that's you're trading for one kind of
stress for a new kind of stress if you
do that
and the change is going to be heartless
all of that right the the work that's
going to go in that you may not have
wanted or thought about and realizing
that's your reality maybe getting
working jobs that are not your favorites
and moving to maybe a new city the
location piece of that so these are all
big changes
but they're possible is and you can do
this yeah you can do it you're getting
ready to be the most courageous you have
ever been in your life
you're getting ready to have a whole new
level of courage right now that you have
never had before do you have good people
in your life liz are you part of a good
church or do you have good mentors or
friends
um yeah i have um i just recently made
um i reconnected with my best friend so
and she's been a really good support
system for me yeah that's awesome i
would get some good people around you
um to i don't want you walking this
alone right because this could be a very
lonely thing um so here's the pain if i
was in your shoes here's the pain i
would choose
i would choose to take a sucky job that
i hate that makes 50 an hour
as long as it's moral and it's legal
okay all right yeah
and because you're not gonna do it long
it's your escape mechanism
you're gonna escape from the little bit
of debt and escape from that house and
get out there and be able to pay your
light bill and put food in the
refrigerator
but you're gonna hate what you're doing
for a little while and then their next
step is to find something that makes
fifty dollars an hour that you love
okay
but you're you're gonna be making some
courageous
uh
high
levels of change
the anxiety associated with change
you're getting ready to swallow a whole
bunch of that
i mean
how old are you liz we were at universal
the other day and we got on this roller
coaster and it went straight up click
click click click i mean straight up we
were on our backs click click click
click click click click click click
click click click and we know what's at
the end of that right as soon as that
thing gets the top we're getting ready
to drop off a 15 story building it was a
blast
that's what you're doing right now click
click click click click click click
you're getting ready to go off
get ready kiddo here it comes
i hope so no it is
it is yeah because it's time you need it
you need it you need to do the brave
wild crazy things that it takes to set
you free don't you
yeah
but don't do this listen you got a
degree in psychology
don't do this while in denial about the
mathematics
okay look at the math the math is your
reality it's saying
i have to do something different and i
have to work a lot more and i may have
to live somewhere else what's the
scariest part liz what's the what's
still the like
you're gasping what's the what's the
scariest part for you well i'm just not
sure if i should be paying off my debt
first no or no i'm just worried no you
need to get out and get a job and get an
apartment that you can afford
okay and then you're gonna save up a
thousand dollar emergency fund that's
gonna be your next goal
and austin will pick up we're gonna give
you a year-long membership to ramsey
plus because that has every dollar the
premium budgeting app i want you on a
budget liz and you know exactly once you
get your job you know exactly where your
money's going and your goal is those
four walls your food your shelter
utilities transportation
and then your next savings goal is a
thousand dollar emergency fund then
after that you can look at your debt but
you're gonna clean this debt up you
don't have a ton right now you're you're
gonna be okay
that's
you're braver than you think you are
kiddo you can do it you're gonna do it
this is the ramsey show
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your
debt-free screen live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
you